>>> THE U.S. SPACE FORCE GRANTED
CNN RARE ACCESS.
JIM SCIUTTO HAS AN EXCLUSIVE
LOOK INSIDE.
>> Reporter: INSIDE MISSION
CONTROL AT BUCKLEY SPACE FORCE
BASE IN AURORA, COLORADO, SPACE
FORCE QUAD GUARDIANS USE SENSORS
THESE SATELLITES ORBITING 22,000
MILES ABOVE THE EARTH FOR
NUCLEAR DETONATIONS.
>> WE NEVER STOP.
ALWAYS VIGILANT AND NEVER FAILED
BECAUSE THAT'S HOW IMPORTANT
THIS IS TO OUR NATION.
WE PROVIDE DATA TO TACTICAL ON
THE GROUND.
>> Reporter: THIS IS MISSILE
SATELLITES DEPLOYED IN ORBIT.
IF THOSE DETECT A LAUNCH
ANYWHERE ON THE SURFACE OF THE
PLANET, IT BEAMS THAT
INFORMATION BACK DOWN TO THIS
GROUND STATION INSTANTANEOUSLY
AT THE SPEED OF LIGHT AND SPACE
FORCE SENDS THAT INFORMATION,
THAT WARNING AROUND THE WORLD TO
U.S. FORCES DEPLOYED ABROAD OR
HERE ON THE U.S. HOMELAND.
IN JANUARY 2020, THESE
SATELLITES SPRANG INTO ACTION
DETECTING MULTIPLE MISSILES FROM
IRAN TARGETING THE AL ASSAD AIR
BASK
BASE IN IRAQ.
BEFORE THE MISSILES REIGNED DOWN
WITHIN MINUTES THEY DELIVERED A
LIFE-SAVING WARNING TO U.S.
T
UNITS ON THE GROUND.
SALLY STEVENS WAS ON DUTY.
>> IT IS LIGHTNING FAST.
>> RIGHT, AND QUICK ENOUGH FOR
THEM TO TAKE ACTION TO PROTECT
THEMSELVES.
>> ABSOLUTELY.
ESPECIALLY IN THE AL ASSAD
NIGHT.
NOT VERY OFTEN DO WE GET
REMINDED WHERE OUR DATA GETS TO
AND THAT NIGHT WAS A SHOCKING
REALITY.
>> Reporter: MISSILE WARNING
SATELLITES ARE A FRACTION OF THE
HUNDREDS OF U.S. GOVERNMENT
SATELLITES MONITORED AND
DEFENDED BY THE GUARDIANS OF THE
SPACE FORCE TODAY DEFENDED
BECAUSE U.S. ADVERSARIES LED BY
RUSSIA AND CHINA DEPLOYED
WEAPONS TO DISABLE AND DESTROY
THEM.
>> IT'S THE REASON WE SIT UP AS
A SEPARATE SERVICE SO EACH AND
EVERY DAY WE TRAIN OPERATORS TO
DETOUR CONFLICT AND COMPETE AND
WIN IN SPACE W.
>> Reporter: THE U.S. HAS MORE
SATELLITES THAN ANYBODY.
A WHOLE RANGE OF U.S. MILITARY
TECHNOLOGIES DEPEND ON THEM.
SATELLITES HELP WARSHIPS AND
AIRCRAFT NAVIGATE AND
COMMUNICATE.
>> MISSILE SUSPENSION RELEASED.
>> Reporter: HELPS SMART BOMBS
AND GUIDED MISSILES HIT THEIR
TARGETS, HELP WAR FIGHTERS
MONITOR THREATS ON LAND, SEA AND
IN THE AIR.
>> THERE IS NOTHING WE DO AS A
JOINT FORCE WHETHER HUMANITARIAN
ASSISTANCE OR COMBAT THAT ISN'T
ENABLED BY SPACE.
>> Reporter: MORE THAN ANY
AMERICANS REALIZE CIVILIAN
TECHNOLOGIES ARE EQUALLY
DEPEDE
DEPENDENT ON SPACE AND SPACE
FORCE BASE IN COLORADO SPRINGS
AT THE BACKBONE OF MULTIPLE
CRITICAL INFRASTRUCTURES.
>> THE FINANCIAL SECTORS RELY ON
POSITIONING AND TIMING
INFORMATION FOR PRECISE BANKING
INFORMATION AND TRANSACTIONS.
THE TRANSPORTATION SEC TOUR,
AIR, LAND, SEA RELY TO BE ABLE
TO EXECUTE OUR CRITICAL
INFRASTRUCTURE.
>> Reporter: THE DANGER OF THE
U.S. IS GREATER DEPENDENCE ON
SPACE EQUALS GREATER
VULNERABILITY TO ATTACKS IN
SPACE.
CHINA IS LAUNCHING KIDNAPPER
SATELLITES WITH GRAPPLING ARMS
CAPABLE OF PLUCKING SATELLITES
OUT OF OR BIT AND RUSSIA IS
DEPLOYING KAMIKAZE SATELLITES
CAPABLE OF DESTROYING U.S. SPACE
ASSETS AND RUSSIA HAS A NEW
SPACE WEAPON, SPACE FORCE DUBS
THE NESTING.
>> BACK IN 2017 RUSSIA LAUNCHED
A SATELLITE AND IT OPENED UP AND
ANOTHER SATELLITE CAME UP AND
THEN IT OPENED UP AND A
PROJECTILE CAME OUT.
THAT PROJECTILE IS DESIGNED TO
KILL U.S. SATELLITES.
SO IN 2019, THEY DID THE SAME
THING BUT THIS TIME, THEY PUT IT
NEXT TO ONE OF OUR SATELLITES
AND THEN WE STARTED TALKING
ABOUT IT.
>> YOU WARNED THEM AWAY?
>> WE DESCRIBED WHAT A SAFE AND
PROFESSIONAL BEHAVIOR AND IT'S
IMPORTANT TODAY, THERE IS NO
RULES IN SPACE.
IT'S THE WILD, WILD WEST.
>> Reporter: FOR THE U.S.
WEAPONIZING, SPACE FORCE WANTS
TO AVOID A SPACE ARMS RACE.
>> WEAPONS IS A LAST RESORT?
>> WE PREFER TO REMAIN FREE OF
CONFLICT BUT LIKE IN ANY OTHER
DOMAIN, AIR, LAND, SEA OR IN
SPACE, WE'LL BE READY TO PROTECT
AND DEFEND.
>> Reporter: ADVERSARIES
ATTEMPTED TO USE SPACE WEAPONS
TO TEMPORARILY DISABLE U.S.
SATELLITES.
SPACE WAR IS NOT SCIENCE FICTION
BUT A BATTLE ALREADY UNDERWAY.
>> THE WEAPON THAT IS ALREADY IN
SPACE, AS WELL, IS LASERS
DIRECTED ENERGY WEAPONS.
THE AGE OF LASERS IN SPACE HAS
BEGUN AND NOT JUST RUSSIA AND
CHINA, IRAN, NORTH KOREA ARE
ATTEMPTING TO TARGET ASSETS IN
SPACE, DEPLOY WEAPON